بطبيعه الحال وسيله الحديث عن عن المنطقه
الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه ونتحدث بدرجه اساسيه
عن خانيونس التي تعود للواجهه من جديد ومع
اعلانات كتائب القسام التي وردت قبل قليل
تقريبا خمس اعلانات اليوم لكتائب القسام
كلها تتركز على منطقه خان يونس والتركيز
على المنطقه الغربيه من خان يونس مع
التوغل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذه
المنطقه لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان خلال
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه ضغط بشكل كبير
من الجهه الشرقيه ومن الجهه الشماليه
الشرقيه وايضا من الجهه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
استهدف بطبيعه الحال منطقه بن سهيلا
وتمركز عند النقطه الغربيه من شارع صلاح
الدين عند مبنى البلديه كما نشاهد في
الخريطه ليكون التركيز الان على هذه
المنطقه التي تشهد اعنف الاشتباكات بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الان
كما ذكرنا يبدا بالتركيز على المنطقه
الغربيه اذا ما دخلنا بصوره اقرب على
المنطقه الغربيه فنحن نتحدث عن مجموعه من
النقاط الاساسيه للاشتباكات التي يحاول
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلالها اختراق هذه
المنطقه والسيطره او التوغل
داخل مدينه خانيونس بشكل اساسي لانه الان
وفق التقديرات يتمركز عند مبنى البلديه في
الجهه الشرقيه من مدينه خان يونس من هذه
الجهه يضغط على وسط المدينه من الجهه
الشرقيه وايضا يتمركز في النقاط الغربيه
من مدينه خانيونس والمناطق الغربيه
الشماليه الغربيه هذه المنطقه التي تشهد
الان اشتباكات من المنطقه الغربيه بين
جامعه الاقصى في هذه المساحه في هذه
المساحه بين جامعه الاقصى في الجهه
الغربيه ومدخل مخيم خانيونس يغلق الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا الشارع شارع البحر يغلقه
بالسواتر الترابيه ويمنع التحرك عليه
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تتمركز في
المناطق الشماليه الغربيه منطقه الصناعه
المنطقه المطله على هذا الموقع موقع
القادسيه العسكري للتدريب العسكري في هذه
المنطقه تتمركز الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وتخوض المقاومه هناك اشتباكات
كتاب القسام كانت قبل قليل قد اعلنت عن
استهداف ل او عمليه مركبه لتفجير منزل
مفخخ ثم استهداف للقوه التي جاءت للاسناد
في هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن المحور الشمالي
الغربي عندما نتحدث عن المساحات والمسافات
في المنطقه الشماليه او في المنطقه
الغربيه من خانيونس فنحن نتحدث عن من
الصناعه الى الاطراف الجنوبيه لمخيم
خانيونس اي اننا نتحدث كما نشاهد على
الخريطه عن مسافه لا تتجاوز 2 كل في هذه
المسافه تخوض المقاومه الفلسطينيه اعنى في
الاشتباكات والاستهداف لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي تسعى للتوغل
داخل مدينه خان يونس عبر المخيم وعبر
منطقه حي الامل والصناعه والمحطه في هذه
المنطقه من المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
الاشتباكات ايضا كان هناك اشتباكات من
الجهه الجنوبيه لمستشفى ناصر في هذه
المنطقه تحاول قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ايضا التوغل كان محيط مستشفى ناصر مجمع
ناصر ومستشفى الامل مجمع الهلال الاحمر
مقر الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني قد شهد
اشتباكات وقصف عنيف لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في هذه المناطق عندما نتحدث عن
كل هذه الاشتباكات والاحداث فهي تدور في
مساحات بسيطه للغايه اذا ما تحدثنا عن
مدينه خان يونس من جهه البلديه اي من
الجهه الشرقيه نحو اطراف المدينه او نحو
اطرافي مخيم خنوس فنحن نتحدث عن 2.5 ك م
من المسافه من الشرق الى الغرب ومن جهه
الشمال الى جهه الجنوب اذا ما تحدثنا من
شارع خمسه الى المنطقه الجنوبيه او
الاطراف الجنوبيه فنحن نتحدث عن 2 م فقط
اذا نحن نتحدث عن حوالي 4 الى 5 م مربع هي
مركز عمليات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
الجهه الغربيه من مدينه خان يونس عندما
نتحدث عن الجهه الشرقيه هناك بعض
الانسحابات في الجهه الشرقيه من منطقه بني
سهيلا الاطراف الشرقيه لبن سهيله طبعا
بطبيعه الحال كان فيها انسحابات في هذه
المنطقه منطقه عبسان وبن سهيله وكان هناك
التركيز والتمركز في الاطراف الغربيه لبني
سهيله لانه كما ذكرنا الاحتلال يسعى للضغط
من بني سهيله باتجاه الغرب وباتجاه قلب
مدينه خان يونس لانه يعتبرها مركز عمليات
كتاب القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه ومركز
الاداره عمليات العسكريه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه هذه الم